I never know who's gonna drop in here in
New York rick pitino stopping by
Continental Tire Coach's Corner got a
book out called my story good to see a
coach how's life it's been hectic has
anything good happen to you I've got to
spend more time with my grandchildren
and that's been terrific what about
professionally anything good you know
the last few years have been difficult
but you navigate and it's tough because
every morning for 40 years you get up at
5:30 what I do is I exercise quickly
rush to the office make my coffee stop I
have my 6:45 meeting then I have four
player development sessions in between
classes exercise at lunch committee a
committee meeting with it with the staff
get ready for practice and then we go
through practice and 14 hours later you
pass out and go to sleep now I get up at
5:30 what am I gonna do rested it down
you know it's tough it's an adjustment
but you have to grow into it you can't
just shrivel up if I gave you a do-over
last couple of years what's what's the
one thing you would change well I would
knowing what I know now I know and I
would certainly it wouldn't be anything
basketball-wise I would certainly make
sure that didn't happen what happened in
that dormitory I don't know how I could
have stopped it
because nobody knew security nobody knew
but I would have found out someway
somehow someway because that's my
brother-in-law's name on that DOMA term
but do you think that aside from that if
that doesn't happen
you're still coaching no question I mean
that was embarrassing to my family to me
the manat EES who the building was named
after I was embarrassing for all of us
it was a it's a very traumatic thing for
that to happen not only uh from soiling
his name on that dormitory but it was a
reprehensible behavior should have never
gone on should never gone on for those
who still believe that you knew knew
something about it
what do you say to them you know it's
it's obvious today that I knew nothing
about it because the NCAA gave me a five
game suspension if they thought I knew
1% of that I would have been been from
coaching for good I'm positive that it
was that reprehensible behavior you
could you can't slap a guy with just 5
games and you're giving other coaches 12
and 13 games for for something like that
so what's the violation the n-c-double-a
gave you well
like why were you suspended five games
because they said I should have when the
recruits were in I should have tried to
notice some red flags and I went back at
them and I said give me a red flag I
should have noticed and they said we're
not saying that there were any but we
wanted you to ask more pointed questions
of the recruit so I would ask on a
Sunday we're done with the weekend I'd
said everybody down and it's okay tell
me about a practice what did you like
about it do you think you can work that
hard tell me who you went out with last
night tell me what play is you got close
to did you like the campus did you like
the academic advisor how about the
strength and conditioning coach how was
your meeting with him we go over
everything in a two-hour period and I
said today the n-c-double-a people know
I never asked the young man did you see
any strippers last night that would be
have been the furthest thing from
anybody's mind because that doesn't
happen it's not normal and it's it's
very abnormal behavior for anything like
that to go on
that being said in my opinion those
players who won that championship
that'll never be taken away because they
weren't on performance-enhancing drugs
they said that was an extra benefit I
mean come on there's nothing extra
benefit about that
so those players won two championship
they deserved that championship it'll
never be vacated the batter could come
down and they could find the school and
they could hit me with a five game
suspension but that championship lives
on forever that tattoos not coming off
you know no it's just to let people know
that you promised the kids that if they
won the national title that you would
get a tattoo right and I walked in a
trainer's room told all the players
that's it guys
no more tattoos we're done with tattoos
everybody's having Bible sayings on
their body they're best friends in life
the girlfriends they dated who they no
longer see around their bodies I said
that's it no more tattoos and they said
okay we'll get no more tattoos if you
get one if we win at all because I just
gave
speech to the team that we're gonna we
lost to Notre Dame in five over times on
the road I wanted to cheer them up there
was this devastating loss I said we're
winning on next sixteen we're going
through the Big East we're not cutting
down the nets we're not cutting down the
nets when we go to the sweet 16 deal
we're not cutting down the nets until we
win it all and they were all pumped up
and that's when they said will you get
what if we went on 16 straight games I
said damn right I will
it sit on your back it's on my back by
my left shoulder okay you're not getting
another one right no not in the near
future do you think you coach again no
way you know I wrote this book for
closure because I don't think I'll have
a coach again and I wanted the truth to
come out in a lot of different things
I'm I don't think a nice university is
going to hire me and I wouldn't want
that I wouldn't want them to go through
it would you hire you no yes what's in
this book is the truth you know I've
always preached to my players tell the
truth and your problems will become part
of your past lie and your problems will
be part of your future the the thing
that that haunts me in my life is an
indiscretion I had many many years ago
and I hurt my wife and family that to me
is much more painful than anything would
basketball and but I had to tell the
truth then and I'll never lie and I
would never know anything about that
under McGee if I did heads would have
rolled within five seconds if I found
out anybody in that dormitory was doing
the wrong thing like you wouldn't
believe
as far as the FBI and what they did to
me in ruining my life it's it's almost
tragic that we hope we taxpayers money
goes for prosecutors to go after
terrorists inside traitors political
corruption guns things that are real
serious in life for them to mention my
name and a complete without a shred of
evidence against me and the fact that I
can't go after them because they have
total immunity it's disgraceful what
they did to put my name in a complaint
without a shred of evidence for only one
reason and I know what the reason is if
they said well we have four assistant
coaches that we're going after and they
named the assistant coaches names
it wouldn't make any news they put me
and Jim Larranaga and Larranaga is one
of the cleanest guys in our game and
fortunately for him he got a two-year
extension but to mention my name would
had any evidence because there were
three phone calls made to this
representative of Adidas Jim Gatto two
of voicemails one if they don't say that
one was to me hey could you give me a
call the second one was I tried calling
you and the third one had nothing to do
with anything
and to mention my name is is just an
absolute disgrace
do you have legal recourse with
Louisville are you suing Louisville I am
I am because they you know is it just
for salary that you're owed yes my
contract now if they would have said to
me then look you've gone through a bad
series here you had you've had 14 great
years and the last two we don't want you
to coach anymore coach this year and
move on I would have said find no
problem at all but they didn't do that
that if Louisville just came out with a
statement said look we apologize we move
forward you didn't do anything wrong
coach but we're moving in separate
directions would you drop the lawsuit
what if that Louisville just apologized
is that good enough it would go a long
way it would go a long way but you know
unfortunately for me I've spent a small
fortune yeah
lawyers are a very very good thing or
they're billable hours and you know what
I had it I had a I had a turn all my I
turned all all over my emails my text
mr. Washington Post right away I've
taken I've been strapped up when a
lie-detector test by by an FBI agent
just to show them that I knew nothing
about this that's not an easy thing to
spend an hour the guy asking you grammar
school questions high school questions
before he gives you two to questions
when you're wired up what are the two
questions did you know anything about
Adidas giving directing any money to
this recruit and the second question did
you have anything to do with any payment
to the Bowen family at all and he's the
recruit but that's where it almost felt
like you were setting yourself up for
being under the microscope where hey
this is the luckiest you know and I'm
paraphrasing you know and we kind of
like I can't believe I got this recruit
like you you sort of set it up we're
like whoa I went out and I found kittens
on my
doorstep here and that's what that's the
way I thought he was he just he drove
six hours in a car with his family
paid for his hotel we went for chicken
at lunchtime and liked it not a
chick-fil-a place but a very inexpensive
plate but it was $24 he paid half we
paid half everything looked totally
aboveboard and I was shocked that we
were gonna get this young man and then
when it turns out I wasn't lucky at all
it was it was being choreographed behind
my back how tough is October November
and October 15th in that first day of
practice well you know dinner I thought
I was sitting on a Final Four team you
never know because you Deleuze Virginia
is coached by I think one of the Great's
in our game Tony Bennett and he loses to
a team that lost to Albany by 40 points
so here's one of the best and that's the
greatest thing about March Madness is
you can lose to anybody you can beat
anybody and it's not like the NBA we're
a seven game series and talent prevails
anybody can beat anybody in an
indicative of what happened to Virginia
so I thought I was sitting on a Final
Four team I had I had length
I had veterans they knew my system we
had guys into junior senior class we
were ready to really have an
unbelievable year and then suddenly he
just said you need to resign I said why
and they said well it's FBI I said they
don't we didn't do anything wrong my
staff wasn't indicted and would you
coach in the NBA I'm done coaching I
really am like if the Nets called you
know III think the NBA's our grind
it'sit's a hundred games ooh MIDI game
and although I'm in great shape it's a
grind and I I don't want to coach I I
miss College terribly it's a big part of
my life but I've got to learn to live
without it and because I know I'm not
gonna coach again would you be an
assistant for your son he wants me to be
his dad his dad do you look back on that
quote when you guys didn't get Tim
Duncan in Boston and you were saying
birds not walking in and no I think it's
great because they always use it I don't
know and I always use it when I say
something you know so-and-so is not
walking through this door now I use it
with other people all the time and I
laugh about
you know one of the things in handling
adversity is you have to have a sense of
humor you know if you can't have left
her in your life and I and I search out
laughter with friends and family to get
through some tough times well the last
thing you want is somebody who's gonna
commiserate with you instead of saying
hey let's liven this up a little bit cuz
yep man you can go into a deep dark hole
oh no question about that and I I search
it out I look for people that want to
have a great time and gonna bring
laughter in your life because look
there's nothing good about the last two
years there's nothing good and people
say oh you should have known you paid a
lot of money no I shouldn't have known
but I hired the person I take full
responsibility and ownership by hiring
that person and and you know what the
saddest thing about it is then I love
the young men I mean he hurt the program
he heard everybody but he was a terrific
young man messes to bring two beautiful
parents I'd like to have you back and
talk some basketball we're gonna have to
go to break here we appreciate it
rick pitino the book is my story
available in bookstores and online great
to you coach thanks for joining us for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]